wow
we're here with adam savage in his
workshop you want a matrix prop
we are excited to learn about some of
the magic tricks that go into these
props to make them look good for camera
i bet you have some crazy stories about
them too to replicate the alien suit
took me 14 years and cost me about ten
thousand dollars
all right today's a very special treat
we usually look at visual effects but
now we're going to look at the real
things practical objects in our hands
we're here with adam savage in his
workshop adam thanks so much for having
us dudes it is so funny to meet you
nice to meet you too yeah i still forget
that you guys actually haven't met yet
until today i can't believe you actually
facetimed in from the hospital during
the birth that was above and beyond the
call of duty but very appreciated when
you're growing up in school like they
ask this question like you know which
two people would you want to have dinner
with and my answer was jackie chan and
adam savage oh my goodness i'm such such
a lustrous company i would love to have
dinner with jackie chan i'm sure he's a
delight taking like one step in here and
you're just like overwhelmed by the
sheer number of things to look at and so
i'm really hoping to get some really
interesting stories about some of these
props here and what they meant to cinema
history so understand also that there
are very few things in this space that
are actually the thing from the movie
funnily enough i'm not that interested
in collecting the real thing because
i want to hand you the thing all right
adam we are excited to learn about some
of the magic tricks that go into these
props to make them look good for camera
and i bet you have some crazy stories
about them too okay i know the perfect
thing to start with here come here
we should see this chewy head
i know it's weird that i've got him in a
kind of an empire box like a yeah it's
like you're a bounty hunter it's like
all right i need my creds the case
thing's going is all part of my
fetishization fetishization of the thing
itself so the whole top comes off
so yeah this is uh this is a chewy made
by tom spina his under skull is actually
made from scams of stuart freeborne's
original chewy head i have i actually
have a casting a soft silicone of what
chewie's face i just really like i've
never seen him hairless
but it's built off of a fiberglass
casting of my head so that when i open
the jaw his lip curls like the real one
and that
that is so i never knew that that was a
thing i never knew they made the lips
curl up with the mouse and that's so
this is a there's actually a great
lineage to this so stuart freeborn who
did chewbacca he also did uh yoda and
actually yoda looks like stuart freeman
if you look up a picture of stuart
freeborn you'd be like oh my god he
sculpted himself
everybody knows it um and that
simplicity of the mechanism of a cable
that's attached to the jaw that simply
when you open the jaw pulls one of the
lips open wait right there
and this is moon watcher
from uh 2001. this is built for me oh
this is built for me by steve neal he
just did an amazing job with this and
here
when you open up his mouth oh it's even
more so yeah you're actually here let me
do this
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
right it's like that looks really good
evolutionary
that lip glow
but that simple thing
that mechanic was invented for this
and then chewbacca got a little bit of
it and it's all this really really low
res low effort excellent activity you
get out of the mask towards the end of
his life i became friends with peter
mayhew and he a more gentle soul you've
never met in your life and he told me
about showing up on episode seven
and i handed him a chewbacca mask with
like 14 servos up in the top and it
weighed like six pounds and he was like
no
take this away take all that out
he doesn't need any of that for his
performance chewie only ever had one
action and that was the lip curl and
you know mayhew brought everything else
to that role in his carriage and his
demeanor and his performance so i
actually have in here everything i need
for taking care of chewie i've got hair
spray i've got some pens i got black
makeup for my
eyes so it's all about i even have a
needle punch for repunching hair if i
need to i'm case obsessed every time i
have an object i want to build a
a display for it worthy of the object
and this is one of my favorite objects
in this whole building
i can't believe i'm actually able to do
this but oh my god
so
this is my iron man mark 1 armor that i
built this was a kit built by some guys
about
2008 that i bought back then on ebay and
there's an aspect of this that i really
want to show you which is
if you look right here it looks like a
pretty good paint job yeah um but when
you
turn your camera on it oh wow it shines
it not only shines but it shows all
these details that your eye doesn't see
and that's a paint job specifically for
the camera so how do you paint for the
camera versus like for eyeballs yeah you
you end up doing things which might look
a little overdone in terms of gathering
color in a corner so i can't help but
notice that
yeah it's not metal no it's resin this
is the whole thing weighs about 25
pounds but you've replicated
crappy welding you know i ended up
taking tons of pictures of military
equipment being cut apart and like
looking at welds and okay thinking about
where where comes in when i was
finishing this there wasn't enough green
in the paint job not enough green in in
this reflective metal paint it's very
subtle but like when i do weathering
videos like never one color to weather
always at least like two and often three
well here's where there's a blue here
there's a very light blue going on here
just to get some kicks here and there to
like
vary it up and make these feel like
different pieces of metal i can see it
now you kind of point it out what's more
important to making something look like
metal the material that you use or the
paint that you use oh the paint it's all
the paint yeah i mean i could i could
make paper mache look like this without
much difficulty
is that a challenge
i actually made the helmet very much
like the real one so it pulls up like
that and has and this is like that
freaking welding
leather yeah it is welding leather
because this was my mythbusters welding
jacket i cut it up so it's got some of
my actual drawings from my midfielder's
welding jacket visible on the inside
that's super cool i also couldn't help
but notice mjolnir and uh stormbreaker
just sitting over here
here grab that whoa
[Laughter]
oh my goodness it's actually cast steel
doesn't that feel great this this is
this feels like what i think storm
breaker should feel like if you picked
it up we actually shot a thing years ago
where we had a thor character in our in
our video and he had like a full-size
like heavy mule ner yeah but like he
wasn't able to like swing it around very
fast even though he's a super buff guy
didn't really look good on camera when
he was like here i'm thor that's why
that's why when you see people fighting
with swords and films this is there's a
sword from one of the narnia films
that is an aluminum blade and when you
swing it around it makes you look
stronger because it's a nice light blade
also you can see this was used for stunt
work because it banged against a bunch
of other swords let's here's another
weta sword
this is from narnia and this is uh the
entire blade is all it's all just one
piece resin with a with a rod up its
middle so it stays stable
and such such
elegant design that's the thing i love
about wet is one of those few places
that when they went from hd to 4k wet it
was like yeah we're good
we're already working at that level of
quality like they do leather work like
this this is all hand stamped at weta
these buckles are cast at weta you know
wow i'd like to think that you have like
a workout place at your home and it's
not like dumbbells and barbells it's all
like it's like swords and like big guns
like you like you know you work your
biceps by lifting up giant like
[Laughter]
all right look i know this isn't adam
savage's workshop um his is a lot cooler
and he's a much better prop maker and a
special effects artist but it's got a
lot of professional tools in here and
that's the point with the right tools
you can make almost anything amazing
beautiful and professional and that's
why courtesy of today's sponsors
squarespace you can make a beautiful
award-winning website for your small
business
nothing says professionalism like a dead
cockroach on the floor and i i know you
might be thinking that's nasty and
that's oh he's not quite dead and that's
because it is nasty unlike our studio
where there's dead cockroaches or nearly
dead cockroaches on the floor packaging
is important and squarespace is there to
help you do that without knowing
anything about web design now there's a
couple ways that they do this first and
foremost they have beautiful
award-winning templates that are
available to everybody who signs up for
squarespace they also have a bunch of
modern incredible tools that allow you
to engage directly with who's on your
site right now
like video blogs audioblocks and
connected social media accounts which
allow you to embed podcasts videos and
connect your social media to display it
directly on your website no need to send
people off to your whatever instagram
just hit them right there while they're
on your site already now another thing
that squarespace has is some of the best
analytics in the game not only is it
important to present your work to your
customer in a beautiful way but also to
understand how your people are engaging
with your creations they give you
traffic overviews they tell you who's
coming into your site and how they're
engaging and experiencing what you have
to offer so that you can make
improvements and make it better and
better over time squarespace also has
built-in members area tools which allow
you to make members area access
available to your audience if you've
ever tried to do that on your own it's
incredibly expensive and time consuming
and squarespace has done that all for
you and don't forget they got that 24 7
award-winning customer service to make
it all go smoothly now if you want to
snip some of those costs and go directly
farm to table directly to your audience
squarespace is a phenomenal tool we've
been using it for years they are
incredible they got a great team so
thanks squarespace not only for that but
also for sponsoring this video if you're
interested in getting 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain click
the link in the description below or go
to squarespace.com
corridor crew that's squarespace.com
corridor crew now
let's get back to that uh workshop
not to hold you to it for the rest of
your life right now at this given moment
we're your like top five films just
right now matrix raiders
you know uh spirited away is absolutely
way in the top five and i won't even
qualify it as animation um there's about
30 in my top five
that sounds about right yeah so you
threw up matrix and raiders at the top
of your list do you have any props here
either from those movies or reproduce
from oh yeah no i got tons i got tons uh
grab your favorites down here here is my
raiders whip that i made it's ten feet
long it's
ludicrously large you could take out a
car headlight with this thing
so i found out that the guy who made the
raiders was david morgan up in seattle
and he's uh david moore is no longer
with us but he was a legend he was a
whipmaker for many years and trained
many of the best women makers in the u.s
he was also the only dealer of kangaroo
hide in the u.s what kangaroo hide is
the strongest leather there is i can
give you a piece a 16th of an inch wide
you won't be able to break it there is
no stronger leather those ruser yes
joey is real
it's not just the muscles that are super
shredded no it's totally uh and so i
called him up and i literally cold
called the company i was like i'd love
to talk to mr morgan about what making
got on the phone and spent 90 minutes
with me on the phone and then he picked
out a hide from me and it matches the
original raiders hide i also have i have
many versions of the headpiece of the
staff of raw but this is my favorite
because it's actually made of bronze
this little detail here on the head
piece of the staff of raw is the cherubs
oh cool
let's uh let's get the matrix props okay
okay i mean the matrix is one of my
favorite films of all time i mean 100 it
should be on everybody's top five list
let's be real the matrix is amazing you
want a matrix prop now how about a
screen used lightning gun
i worked in a little office with uh
nancy noblet and owen patterson she was
the art director owen was the production
designer and at one point after about
six months owen was like have you not
been to the
weapons room and i'm like
weapons
do they keep it on a white sike with a
bunch of racks no
i wish
i was much more space like this
uh and he had you know he handed me this
and i got to hold on to this
that feels like what i expected to feel
like yeah this is from the the second
two matrix films the second and third in
the first matrix film i believe the
screen is on the other side i believe
this this arrangement is reversed
usually a prop master will try and
cobble something like this out of like
they'll find some motorcycle strut yeah
like brushing like the smart gun from
aliens has motorcycle struts mounted to
the front of an m61 or something like
that somebody really worked hard to
design this and then execute it as a
piece of probably laser or water cut
metal to me this has a lot more work in
it
than you often see in a hand prop and
specifically it's all in it feels like
in universe work it was made in zion yes
i can't help but notice you have like a
bunch of spacesuits
yes i have a lot of spaces um i'm
spacesuit obsessed
i am fascinated by humans ability to
engineer their environment to be better
our very hairlessness
and our response to it which was
clothing
allowed us for better or worse to spread
to every corner of this spaceship we're
on that kind of ingenuity thrills me
being one of us being a human being
and someone years ago described the
space suit as an anthropomorphic
spaceship
and that's not that's just a rhetorical
turn of phrase that is actually the most
precise definition you could give of it
we think of the spacesuit as a solved
problem but everyone at nasa will tell
you clearly it's not a solved
engineering problem it's really hard
bodies are so different it's very
difficult to make spacesuits fit all the
different sizes of astronauts
so this is oh cool exactly
one of the helmets from alien wow this
is cast from ripley's helmet from a
screen used piece wow this is exactly
how big they were the detailing on the
inside is all exactly the pieces that
they had on the inside you can see all
this these are bits of like ertl models
and you know you can see truck tires
here oh cool right
this is all original correct detailing
for the alien suit helmet so this is
maybe my favorite spacesuit design in
film history the original design came
from jean giroud mobius who
was a holdover from jordowski's dune art
department when ridley started up the
alien art department and then john malo
academy award winner john molo and his
crew built these suits and they were
just masterpieces of engineering and the
real one actually even looks crappier
than this
up close but it really really sells on
camera i mean what the
what do you need this for yeah what is
that i don't know what that is but it's
so good this is the absolute pinnacle to
me of great design
to replicate the alien suit took me 14
years and cost me about 10 thousand
dollars
because it took me that long to gather
all the parts and do all the problem
solving and find the collaborators and
put it together
this helmet was made by the students of
north bergen high school in new jersey
in two weeks with hot glue and garbage
dude it's i bet you on camera they don't
look too different no no they don't
that's the thing that blows me away
about the work that they did the the
fact that they didn't have this as size
reference and they got so freaking close
i find that almost annoying
frankly i'm a little bit ashamed of
myself that like because every time i
build something from scratch i build it
too big
somehow the camera parallaxing and the
type of adjustments i make i make
everything a little too large exactly
even got like a functional like dome
with windows that's the only thing they
spent money on this was seventy dollars
for the light dome this acrylic
and everything else was pulled out of
dumpsters look at this this is twine
that they've infused with hot glue
to make these lines
there's like these look like the little
injection mold parts for like a gundam
or something like that is this roof from
a model kit and there's a pilot sitting
here
and so in a way the same compromises
remain just how we showed you there's
truck tires on here
their lineage to this is is so much more
direct than they
want
right this to me makes me so happy
that's okay in fact so they put on a
production of alien uh and it got i
tweeted about it it went super viral
online ridley scott paid them to put on
another production of aliens sigourney
weaver went to that production the
xenomorph came out and drooled methyl
cellulose all over sigourney she was
loving it and then ridley actually uh
paid for scholarships for a couple of
the actors from the production to go to
college to be actors absolutely
really really stunning
dude it's just everywhere i look every
possible direction up or down
okay
so oh my god
this
is from an ibm series 703 computer from
1958. this is a bite
one one bite one bite
one bite
that's eight bits because the tubes all
say ibm on them which i think is like
yeah totally freaking awesome
um so
i have because i collect
here is a bit for each of you for your
collection
no
nowhere
no way there's always party favors
and wow so just know like this was so
you could pull it out
and repair the memory one at a time just
like
when my son was in high school he did an
assignment where he's talking about
memory and he came in he took a picture
of this and then we did the math and
figured out that an iphone 3
using this technology would be one and a
half cubic kilometers
[Laughter]
that's how small
there was how small the resistors and
the the the gates in a modern modern
ship are oh my god and that's why movies
didn't use cg until 92 right
holding this wire memory and looking at
these just raw bytes
i mean this is like it's like holding an
old film camera for a cinematographer
but where visual effects are this is
like we have to use memory in our
computers every day and we're so reliant
on it and this is where it all started
this is where i was born this is my
cradle this is what i rested my head on
as a baby
i have this habit in which i can't stop
buying things and i can't stop making
things but they don't have a
commensurate habit of getting rid of
things
and so this becomes this tile puzzle
that gets ever ever closer and ever ever
closer
all right there's like a million stories
here there's more than we can possibly
cover in one video in fact there are so
many stories that we couldn't fit them
all into the youtube version of this
video so the whole thing is up on
quarterdigital.com
go check it out adam's an amazing
storyteller he talks about his time on
mythbusters plus some other crazy stuff
yeah we can't wait to come back and
visit him you are welcome back anytime
you want when you say so many stories
that's actually what this is i realize
it is a palace to objects and the
stories they tell and that i get to
share those stories it's one of the it's
the reason this place exists it's not
just over uh over storage for what gets
built over there in the shop this is
kind of the purpose it is such a delight
to tell stories to folks who are so uh
into those stories it's been a total
pleasure you guys thank you so much
thank you for sharing it not only with
us but honestly with everybody watching
you guys should check out tested it's
adam's channel a whole bunch of other
people work on it as well it's very very
cool you get more insight into this
stuff you get more insight into how
these things are built if you are
interested in these objects these
objects that tell stories and you want
to either know more about them or how to
make them make that kind of stuff
hundreds and hundreds of hours of
showing pills and instructionals and
yeah we're having a lot of fun it's very
enjoyable i love what you guys are doing
on your channel so go subscribe go check
it out yeah thanks for having us
absolutely until next time until next
time